so welcome back to dc thursday everybody
i'm pete soderling i'm the founder of
data council and the data community fund
and i'm here as your guide through the
vast sprawling expanding
modern data ecosystem
and as you know we have highly
interesting and engaging guests on this
show and today is no exception
i'm very pleased to welcome dean
sundstrom
who is most importantly a fellow
minnesotan
and also
the creator of both presto and trino or
the co-creator i should
give proper credit where credit's due
um
currently dana's the cto at starburst
data and
he has a very rich past in software
engineering dating
all the way back to his jboss days
um the i found dane to be a wealth of
information and fun stories uh on on the
tech software engineering ecosystem
um from the past 20 years and
um today we're going to discuss
some of dane's insights including the
one that led to the creation of festival
he was an engineer on facebook
and we'll also hear about some of the
key architectural decisions that were
made when creating that project
we'll also learn about dane's current
work at starburst
and learned why he joined the company
that he believes has the best shot at
becoming the heir apparent to presto
so dane i want to thank you for joining
us and welcome to dc thursday
thank you um it's great it's great to be
here
so um
dane you have an illustrious
background you've served as a software
engineer at many companies many known
companies proof pointing
ibm facebook
obviously now starburst
um i kind of want to want to get the
early scoop from you um how did you get
into software engineering
so uh
funny story
uh you know i i i knew how to program as
a kid uh but i never did it like i mean
programming was like
you know i had a commodore 64. so you
had to write a small program to like
watch a video game that was why i
learned how to program right but i got
to college and my mom was like you're
not taking enough credits why don't you
take this pascal course
and i took it and i was like
wow this is the easiest thing i ever did
it's super interesting
uh like i did really great on all my
assignments i was like great i'll take
more of this and then a few years i
found out like actually this is like a
real big career which is dumb because
this was like
the mid-90s but you know
i was you know a kid not really paying
attention to things so
um
from there i went and worked at united
healthcare and i was like
it's like again lucky and blessed
because i didn't go to like the normal
united health i have a bunch of friends
who work there i worked in the division
that wrote the two the tools for
everyone else
so
i wrote the tools that did like interra
dce which is like a precursor to corpora
and
you know did i i knew how to do windows
programming which none of the other old
unix guys did so i would do the unix
program i would do the windows
programming and like
integrate into uh
now there's like these old weird
programming languages that were kind of
like visual basic and like you had to
integrate your rpc system into it so
that's how i ended up learning like
rpcs and distributed computing and
distributed transactions and
like two-tiered systems and things like
that and this was
97
and so this is like pre ejb pre all that
stuff
and
that's actually why i ended up working
on stuff at jboss
yeah so i knew how to do all this stuff
so so talk to us about that because um
the the early 2000s were sort of you
know formidable
form like uh formative years i should
say in the
ejb java community and you ended up
working on a couple of the
prominent application servers
of their time how did that happen
uh
so after united healthcare i went worked
at a startup and then i started doing
consulting and it was like the boom
right so
i was a very young kid and
at the time i would i would bill people
like oh 175 200 bucks an hour and then
i'd go and work 80 hours a week because
i was a kid
you know and then there was like the bus
started to happen i was like ah this is
exhausting i'm gonna go do something
so i'm like i'm gonna go write a video
game
so two weeks later i'm working on jboss
because i'm like obviously a video game
needs a a distributed computing system
in the back end again like
stupid kid right
and i'm like can't afford to pay for
websphere so i'll just go worst jboss
stuff and i started using it i was like
this thing's super broken
so
and this was back when they were called
ejb oss
and it was like mark fleury and like
four other people like
you know the jetty guys uh james
strachan and
uh
you know but like it's funny because
like all those folks they left and
they're like luminaries but you know and
everyone's like how do you know these
guys i'm like well back in the day
the java community had like i don't know
100 people in the open source who like
we all knew each other like you know uh
i remember when when james duncan wrote
and we're like this is great this is so
much better than using make files right
and so like
all those people started working
together so i i started working on their
uh
container managed persistence which is
they don't have that anymore do they
like
i have not tracked the java world so i'm
not sure i remember ant though
yeah so they used to have this thing it
was like a mapping tool it's like
an old
orm mapping tool but it wasn't like
really based around like
distributed computing concepts so it's
like the works design
anyways they had terrible
implementations so um i wrote the i
rewrote that and then i wrote their uh
it had a uh
a query language in it which was kind of
look like sql and so i wrote the world's
worst parser and analyzer and like would
translate the system and
a few years later someone came along who
knew what they were doing and rewrote it
and i learned a lot
i learned definitely how not to write a
parser and analyze funny
and what was the what was the tren how
did you end up working on both jboss and
geronimo like what what's how did that
happen
so
i mean
there's a long history with mark fleury
like
uh
he is not the um
best business guy and uh
so a bunch of us had been working with
mark and uh
he was running these like training
sessions and um
wasn't really paying people what he had
promised and we all went to some
conference in vegas uh
and
we're in the bus going back to vegas and
someone's like
yeah what's going on with this and then
we all got talking and we decided that
no one wanted to work with mark anymore
so we all split off and it was like
myself the jetty guys uh james strachan
and iran torino and
uh a bunch of these other people and we
formed our own group and we started
working on a new system and that
eventually became geronimo um at the
apache software foundation
um the apache guys recruited us to work
on it there
um
so it was
again this is like the days when
things were a lot smaller like you go to
apache now and they have like 1000
projects or something i don't know maybe
they don't but it feels like it and so
like everyone maybe they do yeah
yeah
[Music]
so again well i wanna i wrote everything
from scratch
yeah interesting
um i mean i definitely want to want to
get to the facebook and presto story but
but before we do that um you had a
couple other companies in between
uh proof point and ning
for sure um were you working on any like
meaningful data stuff in those companies
or i'm kind of curious as to the
transition
you know from the java world into sort
of the more the more data world what did
that look like for you
so eventually
uh
like we sold uh we did a startup and we
sold it to ibm and i worked at ibm for a
few years and then i got really bored
with that
and uh i had a bunch of friends who were
at this company ning and i was like
great i'll move up to palo alto and work
with his company ning
and ning was a social networking company
and i learned a ton of stuff around how
you actually build web scalable systems
and this is like this is early web
scales so like
this is like
it was not even really cloud-based
everything was running on prem but they
built a cloud-based like system so and
then at ning i also spent a lot of time
like in my free time digging into data
systems like i wrote a port i rewrote
memcached in java i rewrote uh some like
berkeley db and a bunch of other things
um
then when i left ning i went to
proofpoint and i still continue like i
still have a fork of like level db that
someone has fork for me because i'm not
a very good maintainer and very busy so
i started doing a bunch of data stuff
there
but
really what i worked on at ning in
proofpoint was
building a platform for
like distributed computing in a modern
web style
um
and so we built this thing called the
proof point platform which later became
airlift after we left proofpoint and
went to facebook
um
and then we built trina on top of that
because that's what we knew
yeah i got it
yeah
that's got it right presto um
so that transition from
um you know what what we were doing
before at a web scale is definitely
something that i think caught a lot of
engineers off guard especially if you
weren't
really working in the bay area um
did you move to palo alto to sort of
take that job at ning or where i'm just
curious where you're physically located
when you're working for ibm at the time
i was in santa monica it was awesome for
like
five blocks from the beach get up in the
morning and go surfing and like it was
great uh
but um
at the time i don't know i hear la has
like a scene now for programming but
like
basically unless you want to make like
firmware for land mines you were in the
wrong city
like there was like a small google
office but it was tiny like you know
so there was like hardly anything going
on in la and i was done working on the
the
stuff with uh ibm and everyone was
remote and i was like i want to work in
an office with people
and i was like great i'll move up to the
bay area and wow like
you know you walk into the coffee shop
here and it's like there's with diffie
sitting there
like it's just a different world yeah
yeah it sure is sure is
um well that's great so so you got in
the web scale game
ning proof point um how did you end up
at facebook like what what's that story
so
we were at proof point and
like
decided like
they
they made a decision that they were
going to like you know have a new
product person which is going to run
stuff and it just wasn't very
interesting anymore so
we had
this friend from
ning sam rash who was
at the data uh group in facebook which
wasn't very big like they just they had
built like this system like stream all
the data in their warehouse and he was
trying to recruit us
and
eventually martine traverso was like
great i'll talk to him and
uh the old vp of engine ning
was the vp of infrastructure at facebook
jay parikh he then became the vp event
at facebook
and so like both of them were like
recruiting us to like we got tons of
interesting stuff in java because
we were like why would we want to work
there like we're the java experts like i
don't want to like work on php stuff and
they're like all our data stuff's in
java
we
they recently lost like the entire hive
team so they had like no one to run
their stuff they need leadership so
they hired us and
uh we worked on some of that data
streaming stuff like um
uh the real-time
processing of real-time streams so
facebook had like the very early version
of this stuff
um
and after a while you mean when twitter
like when twitter was working on storm
and sort of that like that era
yeah when twitter rolled out storm
facebook yeah a much better version
but i mean there's one of those problems
like stuff at facebook is like very hard
to open source those today's wealth and
not because
of facebook but speak of like politics
but because the software is like
a lot of these big companies end up
being like building these like
frankenstein pieces of software where
they're like they use everything the
company already has and like the vast
majority that can't be open source this
is why you don't see a lot of stuff from
google it's just
too hard to like separate it out
and no one's going to give you a budget
to build everything from scratch so like
you have to lean on other people's stuff
um
so like they were all upset and like
well i mean like they push something out
it works so
um
yeah
and uh
so we we got we got asked to replace
this system that facebook team had built
at a hackathon they built a system in c
plus plus it could query hive data
uh and it was used by a ton of people
and it was it was very fast
uh and so they used it for interactive
analytics but then those people quit and
i don't know they were gonna do a
startup or something like that
um
so
we were like hey can you guys maintain
this whatever and we're like we have to
rewrite it because we're not c plus plus
guys
later we found out it was fast because
it didn't process all the data it had
optimizations where it would process for
exactly five minutes and then be like
that's close enough
okay uh
and it would do things like after you
have like you know a thousand groups or
ten thousand groups in your group buy
closets ah that's enough so like they
didn't do any of the hard stuff
everything was like these heuristics and
we're like we need to build a database
it has to return correct answers so we
worked at places where they had these
heuristic systems and the problem is
like if you don't have perfectly correct
answers
people learn to not trust the data
and the answers and therefore like once
trust is gone
you cannot get it back in your data
systems um we learned a bunch of lessons
around like we worked at this place
where they fork the data they put one in
a database and one in a hive system same
data right but each one loses data it's
slightly different or they have slightly
different ways of calculating so someone
run a system over here run one over here
which one's correct
you can burn infinite amounts of
resources in that so
one of the first things we did when we
built uh
trino one of the first press though one
of the first uh tenants was
the answers will always be correct
there is no compromise on that ever
um
and that was a pretty that was a pretty
bold statement at facebook shockingly a
bunch of the other decisions we made
were like
we're going to do anti-sequels people
were mad for like
years they're like why are you not being
hyped we have to learn a new system
we're like
facebook like literally doubled like in
number of employees every two years and
we're like hey like
people know ansi sequel their standard
tools we can hook up to it
uh
and
like in four years like they'll be you
know five percent of the company will
remember we had this conversation
still took them they were still mad the
whole time they're probably still mad
uh and so it was a decision
so you're saying the original presto
came out of this
this hive this sort of system built
around hive to did you say it was to
import or ingest hive data and dive so
the
the
the system at facebook was a fast
interactive system that could do
just aggregations over a single table no
joins no nothing so one of the one of
the things that we made this decision
when we went early was we had a lot of
experience with like traditional
databases like
netezza and teradata and mpp systems and
when we looked at hive and all the other
stuff in the data space we're like this
is just the wrong approach mpp is the
right approach mapreduce is
not the right approach for uh sql
analytics it's
it's there's too much of an impedance
mismatch so we're like we're going to
build a new mpp system we're going to
customize the storage because we knew
storage
optimization is like the golden hammer
of analytics because we use neteases and
we saw what could do if you customize
the storage to exactly match the compute
and so we're like okay we're gonna build
a custom storage system so
big bold plan we had four people
and we're like great let's start by
making the compiler system and the
execution engine so we did that we're
like okay we're gonna need to build a
system to import data into this because
we use again like mutiza and we're like
the worst part is getting data into your
database it's terrible product so we
built these tools to import and then at
a hackathon we're like let's just try
and query directly over this import tool
and
it was super fast like shockingly fast
and so
we decided that ah for now we'll just uh
we'll just go over this import tool
later we'll build a uh in a
ingest system
and
like it was it
we never really got back around to that
because it worked so much and so if like
you look in the
the trino code today you'll still see a
thing called like the hive client which
was the hive ingest client and we had
the mysql ingest client and so you still
see like these lingering things
throughout
um
and
like it was
in retrospect it was kind of this dumb
idea that we would import data because
at the time facebook had i don't know
hundreds of petabytes of data or
something like that
uh now they have insane amounts uh and
you're like i'm gonna create a second
copy of this just for like another
storage system and like this is actually
really common in the industry now you
still see this where it's just like oh
import your data into my system and it's
like
no one like it's it's hard to do it's
expensive
like
and just you can query it directly like
obviously if you organize the data
better the performance goes up
significantly but you can do that in a
object store system if you're clever
and so did that change the the direction
of presto then like was that an insight
that sort of fundamentally changed the
way you thought about this query and
this square well the storage system and
the query engine on top of it yeah so
the the two big changes were we had to
have this abstraction when we were
starting to import stuff
and so that meant that we had actually
abstracted the storage way we always
kept the storage away from the query
engine it was just a thing we did
and therefore we could run the query
engine over really any storage and
that's how we ended up with what people
now call
mesh
mesh
data mesh um
trio had always been built to do that
presto had always been built to do that
and we did it at facebook because
facebook had data silos it's like it's
funny because it's like facebook had all
these problems like five ten years
before everyone else did um and so like
you'd have a data silo that was like the
feed data and the feed people want to be
able to run queries over the facebook
data feed to find people like gaming the
system and things like that there's like
no way to do it we hooked it up to
trino or presto in uh like like a week
and they were able to like find a bunch
of fraud and stuff like that um we
hooked up all of the the mysql storage
systems and a bunch of other things like
people could start joining data across
these and it was just like a huge game
changer um
and that was really fast like in those
days i don't know what hive's like now
but in those days like you brought a
high query and you it would literally
our system would email you when it would
finish that's how long it took like you
go get a coffee
well i remember you saying something to
me um previously about how
there were other reasons that moving
data around
at a company like facebook just became a
non-starter and it wasn't purely for the
technical
uh you know like um annoyance of having
multiple copies of data there were there
were other pressures that started to
emerge
in a literally that had
so much data
yeah
so
everyone's like oh facebook's got
infinite money okay sure but
there's effectively infinite data
because any engineer can add a system
and they generate lots of data so like
you have lots of data you're like great
i want to
like ingest that data
you you have this problem like you only
have so much floor space in your data
centers you only have so many data
centers there are only so many hard
drives in the world so you're like great
we bought all these hard drives then
there's like a tsunami in thailand and
you have to replace every hard drive so
like they bring in truckloads of hard
drives and like it's really complicated
so like everyone thinks that there's
like
these big companies have it easy but
with the bigger size comes bigger data
and so like you have the same problems
just bigger scale kind of things so it's
like oh there isn't enough storage there
was never enough storage there were
never enough computers
every time we onboard new
resources
the internal people would use all of
them they're getting more and more
insights which is like it's great to
have a valuable product but at the same
time if you don't have enough compute
everything slows down so like we had to
build these big systems like ration
compute and this is like you're
rationing compute and there are
literally like 10 000 plus machines
running this thing and you're like i
could use 10 000 more
but where even if you wanted them where
would you get them where would you get
the electricity where would you get the
floor space um
you have this problem that you you
the interconnects between buildings are
really expensive so the storage in the
compute has to be in the same building
or you have to buy interconnects that
are hundreds of millions of dollars
like it's just like
it's one of those like you know
five years ago i was like writing
systems for like oh they got a big
system they have like five computers
when we showed up at facebook we're like
oh we need a test system we're like we
need like two or three vms they gave us
a rack of 30 machines and we're like
well i'm going to do a 30 whole computer
so that's an insane number
right
so it's very ideas
our test system was 500 machines
dedicated just test
because that was our scale test for the
10 000 machine installation like it's
just weird
yeah i guess no one talks about the
logistics
of moving bits around um but you know
that that's a real thing especially at
that kind of scale there must have been
legal
concerns and compliance concerns and all
that other stuff as well that would come
into
moving data around if not then
definitely now
um you know so so these things are
causing more complications as well
yeah the amount of compute that goes
into
data anonymization goes into
uh
like i
i i don't know if they have sovereignty
problems at
facebook i know
lots of customers like we have customers
who are like this data has to stay in
this country this device to stay here
um that's a real deal at facebook
a huge portion of compute time something
like
10
or something maybe more went into like
as new data showed up scanning it to see
if it contains pii
because like when you have that many
employees people don't tag data
correctly and so you're like oh this has
pii in it needs to be tags it has to be
anonymized to mask and like
you know when you're at a small company
you can be like we'll just have people
review it but at some point you're just
like to meet our regulatory requirements
we have to write automated systems to
find this like people aren't good enough
for it
and
it's
yeah it's like
more data more problem the bigger you
are the more product you're gonna have
which is why like it's really important
to have all of this stuff as you're
going through this stage is like making
sure that everything's automated
because as you grow like the next stage
is going to be this new set of problems
you're like what
since when is that a requirement
yeah i get it
um well before we move on from facebook
um anything else interesting there that
uh that you want to share about your
time working there
um
i know it was it was a great time like
it was a
it's
it's fun starting a new project like you
have like a really
a small set of really excited people to
work on stuff it was like a really
really great experience
um they had really
great setup when we first started
working on the project like we were able
to
like you know we showed up and we're
like we'll build this database system
but we're not doing it unless it's open
source from the beginning like it's uh
it's
i
we're a database
and in our estimation it took 10 years
to get a mediocre database and uh
i think we did better than that
but we're at just about 10 years now and
it's pretty good
right
we had a bunch of advantages and it's
like i'm not going to work on something
for 10 years and have it literally die
inside of a company so we went to the
vps and we're like hey we'll want to do
this let's do an apache license so
anyone can use this like it isn't
trapped at this company because like
facebook in all these companies they
change their mind like even if it's
awesome it's like we don't need that
anymore we're gonna do something else
like
i mean i've seen big companies using
open source stuff and now they're on
bigquery
you know
and like their their internal stuff just
dies which is like
it's fine these are like good business
decisions but as an engineer
like it's really really hard if you've
ever worked on something and just seen
it just die internally it's just sad so
so you so you knew that you that you
wanted to and had to fight this
open source battle sort of preemptively
at facebook because it didn't have a
great culture for open source so you
chose to
to make sure and to sort of
um you know use whatever social capital
and political capital you had
to make sure that this project was going
to be able to be open source from
near the inception it sounds like
yeah so that experience came from like
uh
like part of it was you know my
experience at jboss where i saw what
happened when like a company started to
take control of an open source project
so we tried to build a community such
that we wanted the developers involved
in the community to run the community
and we didn't want like politics around
like a big group like apache
and we worked really hard to like build
a diverse community because we didn't
want to be completely controlled by
facebook i learned that ibm like you got
to ask for everything up front
at facebook we asked and they were like
that's a great idea we want to disrupt
the data analytics space anyways so like
let's do it right
but
we we had to ask for was we're going to
build this from open source from scratch
and that means like we're not going to
reuse a bunch of this internal stuff
and again people were mad because like
at these big companies especially as
like facebook went from
this there's tons of interesting
problems to like every interesting
problem has a team on it right and ever
and then there's fifteens and everyone
wants to be involved and expand the
scope of their projects right and so
like you're like i can't use it your
stuff's not open source and people would
get mad about that because like they're
trying to promote their product
right so it was really really important
to
make sure the expectations were set up
front and we did a pretty good job of it
got it got it
well then so you built presto at
facebook um it was a massive success
it started to see
open source traction like like what was
the open source traction like
when you but by the time you left
facebook and did that matter to you were
you sort of
um you know tracking
external committers as kpis and the size
of the community and how did you think
about the
maturity of the project not just in
terms of the bits but in terms of the
community as you mentioned
uh
so
uh
so we definitely did not track the
community as kpis and you can see that
in the community that developed around
it like we had
we had
a
what we thought was a diverse community
of people involved but it was really
like
just people in the valley
and a few startups
that were actively involved in the
product
and
like the community wasn't actually that
active like there was a slack channel we
would talk on the slack channel with
people we would help people out on their
pr's etc
um
so we thought we were doing a good job
because we're measuring against our
peers internally who are like
basically over the wall kind of open
source
um and
like lots of people were using it more
than we expected so we thought we were
doing pretty good once we left facebook
uh
we decided like we decided really
quickly that so
you can go look at our blog we have a
long blog post about why we left
facebook but we left facebook because
facebook wanted to
the management team wanted to take more
control of the open source project and
we weren't down for that like we
originally set up the project to be
as i say real open source like
done open source for a very long time
and i've seen different versions of it
and to me real open source is
run by the people who are actually
writing the software
um not run by corporations or
you know run by a you know
uh yeah i'll leave it there but like run
by the people who run who actually write
software
and
so when it was like oh the management
team was gonna pick who the contributors
were allowed to you know uh contribute
like check-in prs and things like that
we're like yeah we're done
so we decided to
go and leave facebook we're like we're
gonna have to like fork this and set up
a new community well first we tried to
work with facebook and they said
absolutely not so we're like fine we'll
have to set up our own thing so we set
up our own thing and we started like
hey let's set up a slack channel let's
call everyone we know that actually is
involved in this
and we very quickly found that the
community was huge
like
you know we're like oh this is mostly
used in the us and it's like okay so a
third of the traffic came from asia we
didn't know anyone over there who was
using it uh like the the distribution
around the world was basically
wherever there was tech how much tech
there was that was the distribution and
so we started like talking to everyone
we went and helped out a bunch of
companies like uh improved their setups
uh started building community trying to
get more people involved in our
community
um
really grew the slack channel um slack
has been a huge thing for us we do
everything through it um we started
doing
uh
we had we had this uh company in israel
verada invite us to a conference they're
like we want to do a conference just for
presto
you want to come speak and we showed up
and
like literally it was a room for like i
don't know 200 people there were like
people outside lined up like watching on
tv screens out standing outside it was
like it was the craziest thing we're
like
how are there this many people in tel
aviv who know about this like it's a big
city but at the same time like what
and we just started repeating that and
through that you know that year
we rebuilt the community but it was way
stronger like
lots and lots of contributors from
around uh
like lots of people being involved uh
really kind of grew the leader the the
people using it um and it was very much
time well spent um
during that time
we didn't work for anyone we spent like
a year building a new community that was
my next question yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so it's
everyone gets nervous because we're like
the leaders of the project like between
myself martine and david we wrote like a
huge portion of this
and you're like we're trying to build a
real community here and no one believes
you like
what if you're trying to like start a
company at the same time so we're like
we're just not gonna do that like we can
figure that out later what we're going
to do
and our plan actually wasn't to start a
company we're actually going to go try
and find another big company like
facebook who's just willing to pay us to
work on it because
just like writing
running a company is hard
like we're like oh we'll just find uh
you know you know someone to to help us
out and what we want to do and we'll
just go make good money and write this
stuff some more
um
and uh
so that really helped because we would
go and we'd talk to like you know a big
company and they'd be like yeah but you
guys are just gonna we're gonna help you
out and then you're just gonna take this
and you're gonna try and charge us like
you've seen in some open source
companies where it's like open source
project where it's like yep and now
nothing new is gonna happen in the
project like we've been again like
i am a real big believer in like the
communities run by the developers the
people who show up they grow the
software and like
you know um
if some company has commercial advantage
and someone comes along and writes the
same version
it happens like happens to starburst to
this day
like you know we have some advantage and
then someone comes along and writes a
new version it's fine just the way it
goes
and so then well then talk to me about
how
you sort of join forces with starburst
like how did that
actually happen because you have a lot
of like strong values about the way that
the the specific ways that open source
needs to be open and obviously that
comes across in a lot of these stories
which is amazing um tell us how
how that whole union ended up happening
so
starburst
uh originally
back in the day there was a company
called adapt
which was
uh
the ceo of starburst justin boardman and
a bunch of engineers plus uh
daniel abadi i think it was his idea
and they had a version of hive where the
back end storage was actually postgresql
and there's a bunch of papers on this
it's a very cool idea just doesn't scale
or doesn't run very well in the cloud
and eventually they got bought by
teradata
and
when they joined teradata they're like
our idea doesn't have legs people aren't
jumping on it it's not a um
it's just not what the community wants
and so they're like where can what can
we go work on so they went and talked to
the high people they talked to a bunch
of other groups and they found uh what
we were doing at facebook with presto
and within like a month or two from when
we had uh open sourced it
they flew out to
california and we had a couple of
meetings and they decided that they were
going to focus on
uh
commercializing around uh presto we were
like this is great because at facebook
there are all these things that
just can't really get the resources to
build that like commercial companies
need like
really deep
integrations with um
like facebook has one security system
there's one authentication system it's
like building that stuff out like we
never had the time to do it and so they
were building that out in the community
and they were reselling it through
teradata
and
that worked for a while until teradata
decided that they were going to cut
everything
that wasn't making a lot of money
and uh they cut
the trinos the the presto stuff and they
cut like there's a bunch of other like
data luminaries that used to work there
that no longer work here because they
cut everything
and uh the
so after that the the
folks who had built uh adapt and then at
teradata they're like we're gonna do a
startup
and so
they bootstrapped the startup for a
while after we left they're like you
should come work with us and we're like
yeah but we can't do that because
that'll freak everyone out like
and i'm not sure we want to do a startup
right
later that year after we're like okay we
need to figure out what we're doing we
looked at a bunch of options and we had
a bunch of long conversations with
justin around what we wanted to do um
and
sort of worked it out but then mike
foltby was like this thing would be mike
fulpy's one of our investors he's the
lead investor at index
and uh
he's like this would be amazing if
youtube groups got together he's like
i'm gonna make that happen
uh and i'd known mike and you know he
wanted us to do something and
like everyone wanted us to do something
but we're like we don't want to do
startups and we'll have to fight with
like starbursts and varada and all these
other companies we like
like how do we actually do something and
work it out and so
we eventually came to a deal with
starburst and it has worked out really
well um
and a lot of credit goes to volpe a lot
of credit goes to justin
for like
being able to like see what it looks
like all put together
and the team is just amazing
it's very
that's cool
and so just just to finish the last bit
of it um you know just so folks
understand
the how how sort of presto became
trina or a version of presto became
trino um there's other big company
dynamics that still exist
um inside facebook that you sort of
alluded to
um that you know the powers that be sort
of wanted to prevent um you folks from
using the presto name
um you know let's say that's that's
their right um regardless of where you
personally stand on that and so
and so you renamed your fork ultimately
to trino just for the clarity of the
community
yeah
yeah and
it's one of those things where like we
should have done it before like actually
like
the idea that the names actually matter
that much like my advice to everyone is
like they actually don't matter that
much what matters is the good will that
comes from the community
and we should have probably changed the
name
long before um and it would given us
more time to build up the brand um and
like
you know now we have this amazing new
logo and
i love the space bunny and you know like
all the all the you know
trinomialisms i'm seeing sort of like
surrounding you it's uh it looks like a
fun
it looks like a very fun branch um let's
just say that yes
it probably belies the seriousness like
below below the covers
it's it's funny because our uh
our
our original presto brand is like really
stodgy
and we're like oh we want to look like a
traditional database company and when we
did the rebound i was like let's do the
opposite let's do something super fun
like you know and we have this amazing
designer and i'm like this is all like
traditional blue kind of ibm colors like
let's do something like pink and purple
and like just out there and they're all
like i don't know it was i loved it
well it's i i think i i agree it's
refreshing and it's nice to have um you
know sort of a different kind of a data
point in the space
so so dane um you know we only have a
few minutes left but but i do want to
hear from you sort of um you know some
of the goodness that you've been working
on recently because
i know there's galaxy which is hosted
stuff
um i know there's a roadmap for trino
that you're excited about um talk to us
a little bit about you know we got so
much fun like rich history which was
really enthralling and thank you for
that um but i want to give you a chance
to talk about some of the technical
stuff that you're really proud of
you and your team are working on as well
so i for the past like year or so we've
been working on a
fast-hosted version of trino at uh
starburst
and it's called galaxy and
i love it it's like i love working on
this project so like in trino
uh
we
trino's all about like running
everywhere with everyone's stuff right
and so like there's only so much the
community can do like
you when you get to the edges of the
project where you're like oh i think
let's integrate with the security system
there are like seven security systems in
the world and so like we can only build
so much then there's plug-ins but like
each layer you go out you get
less and less of the community involved
in it to the point where like you'll
have like one person who's using
something
and they may go away and they may come
back
and with
galaxy i
we get the opportunity to like build up
the whole system all the way out into
like the edges and like have a fully
integrated experience so it's like
there's a fully integrated security
system that like affects the whole
system um you know we
because we're only targeting like we're
targeting just the clouds so we're in
three clouds and we're able to like
build these really deep integrations
with the clouds because we only need to
run in like one environment the
starburst environment that like has very
specific setups so it's actually it's
more like coding at facebook where
there's like there's one environment
that you code to you yeah and whereas
like trino is like they're like
thousands of environments there's really
like you know we have people using trino
who have like 20 ldap systems that all
have to be integrated into like the
security system for logging you're like
why would you do that right
so like i love this because we can
actually like build out these deeper
things that like the community just
stopped at and that are like super
interesting and fun
so like there's this whole like
integrated experience like uh i
anyone who's interested in should
definitely go try it out you can sign up
in like a couple of minutes and boom
you're just online and working which is
you know i don't have to explain to
people how to set everything up and
install it and connect to other things
like it just kind of does it for you so
it's something i've been really excited
about because i think it lowers the bar
for like using katrina and i want more
people using it like i love this
software
um
so with so with galaxy um does your data
sort of sit like in it in its existing
place and this is a managed control
plane this is sort of the control plane
idea that we're starting to emerge in um
in other sort of cloud-hosted data
systems
yeah yeah so we connect to the data in
your uh cloud account so we'll connect
to like your object storage or your my
sequels or redshift or like whatever you
have you know
and
we
you're able to run queries over it we
handle managing the compute we handle
the security we'll integrate into your
security
into like uh
we're just finishing up our sso
integration so we'll integrate to the s
so
things like that so like the idea is
like
you bring
the data will hook everything else up
and it just works for you and it's
secure and it's you know reliable and
not complicated
i was like
we spent a lot of time trying to make
trino easy to set up and it is
but it is still very hard
got it
well that that sounds like a very cool
product and and i'm sure um lots of
folks in our community will
find it useful um and talk to us a
little bit about the roadmap like um do
you see the uh
as cto do you see the commercial road
map
different than the open source road map
do you try to control both like talk to
me a little bit about how you see that
and and what we have to look forward to
on either or both sides
so
on the
commercial roadmap
i mostly focus on our sas product we
have an on-prem product also
and
most of our stuff on the commercial
roadmap is improving this overall
experience and helping you know
make it easier to connect in your data
and make it secure and reliable and all
that sort of stuff so it's like
like i think it is like the icing on top
of like the trio right
um on the open source side
obviously we do not control the road map
that's the the the community we have a
bunch of developers that are working on
stuff that we're interested in starburst
so
some of the stuff i'm really excited
about is this uh granular fault
tolerance stuff that uh we've been
working on um it's led by andre which is
a person who used to work at uh at adapt
back in the day and then went to
facebook and now it's building this
stuff at uh starburst for the community
um and it
basically allows us to run very large
batch jobs completely fault tolerant at
you know trino speeds so
uh these very large jobs are
are not going to be a problem or
actually i think it's all in now i think
they they said they checked it in
yesterday and it's been a release so
uh it's it's uh it's pretty awesome and
i'm excited for the new it's like a new
execution scheduling model and i'm
curious to see how much farther we can
go
we have stuff around um
there's there's a bunch of new awesome
features in sql that like not everyone
knows about so there's this thing called
polymorphic table functions which allows
you to
integrate things like in the middle of
your query you can be like process these
rows through this function which takes
rows and
transforms an output new rows and the
function itself can be like i'm a
python script and when i process the
rows the output schema is this that's
why they're they're called polymorphic
because they can change the output based
on what's in the script
and so it allows you to integrate things
like scripts or
raw sql paths through or
complex
non-relational things like you know uh
approximate top-end things or heck you
probably even put machine learning into
it if you're clever enough
um so it's just what i like about it
it's very powerful thing that opens up
the creativity of the community to
figure out like okay we have this place
where we plug this in what can we do
with this right
um and this is part of the nc the ansi
standard yes yeah it's been there for
two years or something like that they're
all these like
the other one of the other things is
like these new json functions that are
like super awesome that like not a lot
of people know about so like we very
closely follow the specs i mean i love
specs all the way back to my ejb
it's like we follow the specs and
there's like some really really awesome
ideas in there and we're implementing
them as you know we can
um
the other big thing is we're moving to
java 17 soon
and it's such a better programming
experience anyone who's used it like it
will blow your mind it's like a another
game changer like the java team has done
something really amazing here
um and part of that is there's this new
cindy system so we're
starting to invest in
uh
you know in in trying to figure out how
we can do
more cindy stuff like we've done a bunch
of experimentation
there's um which in it can improve some
some computations considerably um
so there we go there there we are i lost
you for a second sorry about it yeah
um so it can improve some computation
some parts of the computation like a
couple of x it's very interesting how
you actually get it into a system and
pull it off and make it efficient and
actually work
um there's a million papers in the data
space about using ximdi
and not a lot of people are using it
because
the reality is when you get into a big
system it doesn't work very well um but
there are ways to pull it off and
where we've done some experiments and
we'll see more over the next years i'm
pretty excited about what's going on in
that space
um
very cool well um yeah thanks for
sharing with us
some of the what we have to look forward
to as a community um in future versions
of trino and
um dana's been really awesome to have
you i i need to let you get back to work
because you know we could talk like this
all morning
um and the stories that you have from
from who you've worked with and what
you've seen in the past is really
like tickling to me because
um yeah i've been in tech for a long
time as well i was more on the east
coast side and so it's great to hear
about some of these these bear stories
um so thanks for your contribution to
the open source world and i can tell
your passion and your fire for it um
really drives you so
um i
i think and i hope that you found the
best place for you
the starburst um and i know that they'll
be a good steward of the resources that
they throw against the the trino project
and i'm sure you're happy to see that
and and you're also
welcoming to the rest of the community
to continue just to contribute and
support the project which
is amazing so
so thanks for your enthusiasm for open
source it's really been um great to have
you on the show
i appreciate it this was a lot of fun
and thanks to our listeners um
make sure you don't miss data council
austin which is next week it's gonna be
our largest event ever so please make
sure and join us irl
and as far as dc thursday we'll have our
next event on april 7th where we'll be
talking about feature engineering with
patrick thompson from rasco
so don't forget